today i'd like to share with you three
fake proofs in increasing order of
subtlety and then discuss what each one
of them has to tell us about math
the first proof is for a formula for the
surface area of a sphere and the way
that it starts is to subdivide that
sphere into vertical slices the way you
might chop up an orange or paint a beach
ball we then unravel all of those wedge
slices from the northern hemisphere so
that they poke up like this and then
symmetrically unravel all of those from
the southern hemisphere below and now
interlace those pieces to get a shape
whose area we want to figure out the
base of this shape came from the
circumference of the sphere it's an
unraveled equator so its length is two
pi times the radius of the sphere
and then the other side of this shape
came from the height of one of these
wedges which is a quarter of a walk
around the sphere and so it has a length
of pi halves times r the idea is that
this is only an approximation the edges
might not be perfectly straight but if
we think of the limit as we do finer and
finer slices of the sphere this shape
whose area we want to know gets closer
to being a perfect rectangle one whose
area will be pi halves r times two pi r
or in other words pi squared times r
squared
the proof is elegant it translates a
hard problem into a situation that's
easier to understand it has that element
of surprise while still being intuitive
it's only fault really is that it's
completely wrong the true surface area
of a sphere is 4 pi r squared i
originally saw this example thanks to
henry reich and to be fair it's not
necessarily inconsistent with the 4 pi r
squared formula just so long as pi is
equal to four
for the next proof i'd like to show you
a simple argument for the fact that pi
is equal to four
we start off with a circle say with
radius one and we ask how can we figure
out its circumference after all pi is by
definition the ratio of this
circumference to the diameter of the
circle we start off by drawing the
square whose side lengths are all
tangent to that circle
it's not too hard to see that the
perimeter of the square is eight
then and some of you may have seen this
before it's a kind of classic argument
the argument proceeds by producing a
sequence of curves all of whom also have
this perimeter of 8 but which more and
more closely approximate the circle but
the full nuance of this example is not
always emphasized first of all just to
make things crystal clear the way each
of these iterations works is to fold in
each of the corners of the previous
shape so that they just barely kiss the
circle and you can take a moment to
convince yourself that in each region
where a fold happened the perimeter
doesn't change for example in the upper
right here instead of walking up and
then left the new curve goes left and
then up
and something similar is true at all of
the folds of all of the different
iterations wherever the previous
iteration went direction a then
direction b the new iteration goes
direction b then direction a but no
length is lost or gained some of you
might say well obviously this isn't
going to give the true perimeter of the
circle because no matter how many
iterations you do when you zoom in it
remains jagged it's not a smooth curve
you're taking these very inefficient
steps along the circle while that is
true and ultimately the reason things
are wrong if you want to appreciate the
lesson this example is teaching us the
claim of the example is not that any one
of these approximations equals the curve
it's that the limit of all of the
approximations equals our circle and to
appreciate the lesson that this example
teaches us it's worth taking a moment to
be a little more mathematically precise
about what i mean by the limit of a
sequence of curves
let's say we describe the very first
shape this square as a parametric
function something that has an input t
and it outputs a point in 2d space so
that as t ranges from zero to one it
traces that square i'll call that
function c zero and likewise we can
parametrize the next iteration with a
function i'll call c1 as the parameter t
ranges from zero up to one the output of
this function traces along that curve
this is just so that we can think of
these shapes as instead being functions
now i want you to consider a particular
value of t maybe 0.2 and then consider
the sequence of points that you get by
evaluating the sequence of functions we
have at this particular point now i want
you to consider the limit as n
approaches infinity of c sub n of 0.2
this limit is a well-defined point in 2d
space in fact that point sits on the
circle and there's nothing specific
about 0.2 we could do this limiting
process for any input t and so i can
define a new function that i'll call c
infinity which by definition at any
input t is whatever this limiting value
for all the curves is
so here's the point
that limiting function c infinity
is the circle it's not an approximation
of the circle it's not some jagged
version of the circle it is the genuine
smooth circular curve whose perimeter we
want to know
and what's also true is that the limit
of the lengths of all of our curves
really is eight because each individual
curve really does have a perimeter of
eight
and there are all sorts of examples
throughout calculus when we talk about
approximating one thing we want to know
as a limit of a bunch of other things
that are easier to understand
so the question at the heart here is why
exactly is it not okay to do that in
this example
and maybe at this point you step back
and say you know it's just not enough
for things to look the same this is why
we need rigor it's why we need proofs
it's why since the days of euclid
mathematicians have followed in his
footsteps and deduced truths step by
step from axioms forward but for this
last example i would like to do
something that doesn't lean as hard on
visual intuition and instead give a
euclid style proof for the claim that
all triangles are isosceles the way this
will work is we'll take any particular
triangle and make no assumptions about
it i'll label its vertices a b and c
and what i would like to prove for you
is that the side length a b is
necessarily equal to the side length ac
now to be clear the result is obviously
false just in the diagram i've drawn you
can visually see that these lengths are
not equal to each other
but i challenge you to see if you can
identify what's wrong about the proof
i'm about to show you honestly it's very
subtle and three gold stars for anyone
who can identify it
the first thing i'll do is draw the
perpendicular bisector to the line bc so
that means this angle here is 90 degrees
and this length is by definition the
same as this length and we'll label that
intersection point d
and then next i will draw the angle
bisector at a which means by definition
this little angle here is the same as
this little angle here i'll label both
of them alpha and we'll say that the
point where these two intersect is p
and now like a lot of euclid-style
proofs we're just going to draw some new
lines figure out what things must be
equal and get some conclusions for
instance let's draw the line from p
which is perpendicular to the side
length ac and we'll label that
intersection point e
and likewise we'll draw the line from p
down to the other side length ac again
it's perpendicular and we'll label that
intersection point f my first claim is
that this triangle here which is afp is
the same or at least congruent to
this triangle over here a e p
essentially this follows from symmetry
across that angle bisector
more specifically we can say they share
a side length and then they both have an
angle alpha and both have an angle 90
degrees so it follows by the side angle
angle congruent relation maybe my
drawing is a little bit sloppy but the
logic helps us see that they do have to
be the same next i'll draw a line from p
down to b and then from p down to c
and i claim that this triangle here is
congruent to
its reflection across that perpendicular
bisector again the symmetry maybe helps
make this clear but more rigorously they
both have the same base they both have a
90 degree angle and they both have the
same height so it follows by the side
angle side relation so based on that
first pair of triangles i'm going to
mark this side length here as being the
same as this side length here marking
them with double tick marks
and based on the second triangle
relation i'll mark this side length here
as the same as this line over here
marking them with triple tick marks and
so from that we have two more triangles
that need to be the same namely this one
over here and the one with corresponding
two side lengths over here and the
reasoning here is they both have that
triple ticked side a double ticked side
and they're both 90 degree triangles so
this follows by the side side angle
congruence relation
and all of those are valid congruence
relations i'm not pulling the wool over
your eyes with one of those
and all of this will basically be enough
to show us why a b has to be the same as
bc
that first pair of triangles implies
that the length af is the same as the
length ae those are corresponding sides
to each other i'll just color them in
red here and then that last triangle
relation guarantees for us that the side
fb
is going to be the same as the side ec
i'll kind of color both of those in blue
and finally the result we want basically
comes from adding up these two equations
the length af plus fb is clearly the
same as the total length a b
and likewise the length a e plus e c
is the same as the total length ac
so all in all the side length a b has to
be the same as the side length ac and
because we made no assumptions about the
triangle this implies that any triangle
is isosceles
actually for that matter since we made
no assumptions about the specific two
sides we chose it implies that any
triangle is equilateral
so this leaves us somewhat disturbingly
with three different possibilities all
triangles really are equilateral that's
just the truth of the universe or you
can use euclid-style reasoning to derive
false results or there's something wrong
in the proof but if there is where
exactly is it
so what exactly is going on with these
three examples
now the thing that's a little bit
troubling about that first example with
the sphere is that it is very similar in
spirit to a lot of other famous and
supposedly true visual proofs from
geometry for example there's a very
famous proof about the area of a circle
it starts off by dividing it into a
bunch of little pizza wedges and you
take all those wedges and you straighten
them out essentially lining up the crust
of that pizza
and then we take half of the wedges and
inter-slice them with the other half and
the idea is that this might not be a
perfect rectangle it's got some bumps
and curves but as you take thinner and
thinner slices you get something that's
closer and closer to a true rectangle
and the width of that rectangle comes
from half the circumference of the
circle which is by definition pi times r
and then the height of that rectangle
comes from the radius of the circle r
meaning that the whole area is pi r
squared
this time the result is valid but why is
it not okay to do what we did with the
spheres but somehow it is okay to do
this with the pizza slices
the main problem with the sphere
argument is that when we flatten out all
of those orange wedges if we were to do
it accurately in a way that preserves
their area they don't look like
triangles they should bulge outward and
if you want to see this let's think
really critically about just one
particular one of those wedges on the
sphere and ask yourself how does the
width across that wedge this little
portion of a line of latitude vary as
you go up and down the wedge in
particular if you consider the angle phi
from the z axis down to a point on this
wedge as we walk down it what's the
length of that width as a function of
phi for those of you curious about the
details of these sorts of things
you'd start off by drawing this line up
here from the z-axis to a point on the
wedge its length will be the radius of
the sphere r times the sine of this
angle that lets us deduce how long the
total line of latitude is where we're
sitting it'll basically be 2 pi times
that radial line 2 pi r sine of phi and
then the width of the wedge that we care
about is just some constant proportion
of that full line of latitude now the
details don't matter too much the one
thing i want you to notice is that this
is not a linear relationship as you walk
from the top of that wedge down to the
bottom letting fee range from zero up to
pi halves the width of the wedge doesn't
grow linearly
instead it grows according to a sine
curve
and so when we're unwrapping all of
these wedges if we want those widths to
be preserved they should end up a little
bit chubbier around the base their side
lengths are not linear
what this means is when we try to
interlace all of the wedges from the
northern hemisphere with those from the
southern there's a meaningful amount of
overlap between those non-linear edges
and we can't wave our hands about a
limiting argument this is an overlap
that persists as you take finer and
finer subdivisions
and ultimately it's that overlap that
accounts for the difference between our
false answer with a pi squared from the
true answer that has four pi
it reminds me of one of those
rearrangement puzzles where you have a
number of pieces and just by moving them
around you can seemingly create area out
of nowhere for example right now i've
arranged all these pieces to form a
triangle except it's missing two units
of area in the middle now i want you to
focus on the vertices of that triangle
these white dots those don't move i'm
not pulling any trickery with that but i
can rearrange all of the pieces back to
how they originally were so that those
two units of area in the middle seem to
disappear all the constituent parts
remain the same the triangle that they
form remains the same and yet two units
of area seem to appear out of nowhere
if you've never seen this one before by
the way i highly encourage you to pause
and try to think it through it's a very
fun little puzzle
the answer starts to reveal itself if we
carefully draw the edges of this
triangle and zoom in close enough to see
that our pieces don't actually fit
inside the triangle they bulge out ever
so slightly
or at least arranged like this they
bulge out ever so slightly when we
rearrange them and we zoom back in we
can see that they dent inward ever so
slightly
and that very subtle difference between
the bulge out and the dent inward
accounts for all of the difference in
area the slope of the edge of this blue
triangle works out to be five divided by
two whereas the slope of the edge of
this red triangle works out to be seven
divided by three those numbers are close
enough to look similar as slope but they
allow for this denting inward and the
bulging outward you have to be wary of
lines that are made to look straight
when you haven't had explicit
confirmation that they actually are
straight
one quick added comment on the sphere
the fundamental issue here is that the
geometry of a curved surface is
fundamentally different from the
geometry of flat space the relevant
search term here would be gaussian
curvature you can't flatten things out
from a sphere without losing geometric
information
now when you do see limiting arguments
that relate to little pieces on a sphere
that somehow get flattened out and are
reasoned through there those only can
work if the limiting pieces that you're
talking about get smaller in both
directions it's only when you zoom in
close to a curved surface that it
appears locally flat
the issue with our orange wedge argument
is that our pieces never got exposed to
that local flatness because they only
got thin in one direction they maintain
the curvature in that other direction
now on the topic of the subtlety of
limiting arguments let's turn back to
our limit of jagged curves that
approaches the smooth circular curve as
i said the limiting curve really is a
circle and the limiting value for the
length of your approximations really is
eight
here the basic issue is that there is no
reason to expect that the limit of the
lengths of the curves is the same as the
length of the limits of the curves and
in fact this is a nice counter example
to show why that's not the case
the real point of this example is not
the fear that anyone is ever going to
believe that it shows that pi is equal
to four instead it shows why care is
required in other cases where people
apply limiting arguments for example
this happens all throughout calculus it
is the heart of calculus where say you
want to know the area under a given
curve the way we typically think about
it is to approximate that with a set of
rectangles because those are the things
we know how to compute the areas of you
just take the base times height in each
case now this is a very jagged
approximation but the thought or i guess
the hope is that as you take a finer and
finer subdivision into thinner and
thinner rectangles the sums of those
areas approaches the thing we actually
care about
if you want to make it rigorous you have
to be explicit about the error between
these approximations and the true thing
we care about the area under this curve
for example you might start your
argument by saying that that error has
to be strictly less than the area of
these red rectangles essentially the
deviation between the curve and our
approximating rectangles sits strictly
inside that red region and then what you
would want to argue is that in this
limiting process the cumulative area of
all of those red rectangles has to
approach zero
now as to the final example our proof
that all triangles are isosceles let me
show you what it looks like if i'm a
little bit more careful about actually
constructing the angle bisector rather
than just eyeballing it when i do that
the relevant intersection point actually
sits outside of the triangle and then
from there if i go through everything
that we did in the original argument
drawing the relevant perpendicular lines
all of that every triangle that i
claimed was congruent really is
congruent all of those were genuinely
true and the corresponding lengths of
those triangles that i claimed were the
same really are the same
the one place where the proof breaks
down is at the very end when i said that
the full side length ac was equal to ae
plus ec
that was only true under the hidden
assumption that that point e sat in
between them but in reality for many
triangles that point would sit outside
of those two it's pretty subtle isn't it
the point in all of this is that while
visual intuition is great and visual
proofs often give you a nice way of
elucidating what's going on with
otherwise opaque rigor
visual arguments and snazzy diagrams
will never obviate the need for critical
thinking in math you cannot escape the
need to look out for hidden assumptions
and edge cases
[Music]
you